good job the bow don't sweat now feel
swell
you got only two beautiful Tony I'm
gonna burn my troubles away I'm going
just a heads up for all you waistline is
out there this episode of the fallout 4
show may contain some minor spoilers
fallout 4 is full of beautiful little
moments when you get your face just
right in the character creator when you
first meet dogmeat and that first
gorgeous visceral head explosion
courtesy of vats a shotgun and are not
so willing volunteer but we know you
guys like lists so we've narrowed it
down to the five best moments in fallout
4 so far we're talking tingles down the
spine tears in the eyes white-knuckle
controller grasping moments that have
really defined our time in Boston so far
if you think we've missed out something
huge or if you have your own special
moments from the game tell us in the
comments just try not to post any
spoilers our first moment it's probably
the most superficial once you've
perfected your face or made the ugliest
person possible for some of you it's
time to get out there and what remains
of Boston but are you really wearing
that blue and yellow is so 200 years ago
Boston is littered with outfits from
baseball uniforms and fifties dresses
too hideous suits and even just your
underwear which is somehow not
disintegrated in the past 200 years so
whether you're a tunnel snake reborn or
trying to blend in with the Raiders
you've got your pick of the wasteland
don't let yourself be satisfied with
second-rate boiler suits that probably
smell like centuries of sweats find
yourself the perfect outfit once you're
kitted out like the biggest badass in
Boston everything else just falls into
place the dynamic weather in fallout 4
makes for some excellent emergent
gameplay fighting death goals in the
rain gazing out across Boston as the Sun
peeks out from behind the clouds lovely
stuff but it's the random terrifying
radiation storms that really seal the
deal for us
your first radiation storm is incredible
the sky darkens a thick green fog
settles in and a rad spike as bright
lightning Forks across the murky smog if
you hadn't already heard from Todd
Howard that this would happen or if you
did and forgot it's really bloody
frightening the storms originate from
the glowing sea the place the bomb drops
still pretty dangerous 200 years on
unless you enjoyed choking on
carcinogenic dust and walking through
molten irradiated goop that probably
used to be
people in a way they're a teaser for the
glowing sea a little taste of how many
rads you can handle we had to include
settlements in the list that the biggest
newest feature in fallout since the
bombs themselves and there's nothing
more satisfying than plunking down guard
posts turrets wooden shacks and huge
[__] off towers that are in no way
compensating for anything okay it can be
a bit fiddly and you do sometimes end up
with floating walls and fences but the
payoff is worth it when you have a bunch
of well-fed happy peeps roaming about in
armor carrying shotguns and sleeping in
your comfy cozy houses in the Betsi
built for them it's heartwarming you've
basically built yourself a large and
slightly more complicated Tamagotchi
while you're off having adventures your
settle is a living loving and then you
periodically come back to giving your
scraps to live off and they love it most
fights in Fallout aren't that surprising
because they normally begin with someone
yelling who's that how did you get in or
I'm gonna bite your head off like your
grandma when she watches The X Factor
but animals are less predictable unless
you're really vigilant you'll get jumped
by a deathclaw or a yokai at least once
and that's where it gets really fun
the first deathclaw fight scripted
though it is makes you poop your
two-hundred-year-old pants they have a
completely awful way of just appearing
out of nowhere
despite their gigantic size and tearing
you to shreds every encounter afterwards
is just as thrilling terrifying and full
of adrenaline as the first but in the
same way a roller coaster that pretends
to kill you is exciting we can't help
feeling all tingly when we're standing
over the corpse of a 400-pound creature
that just a few seconds ago was sticking
its claws down your throat and then you
can go and funnel all that adrenaline
into exploding more Raider heads even if
they aren't quite as challenging an
enemy vault 111 is let's face it a bit
dull all of its inhabitants don't really
have much to say and the worst you'll
find is a few rogue radroaches
but there are other vaults out there in
Boston and you'll never forget your
first we won't spoil too much for you
here because that's not nice but vaults
have always been the backbone of Fallout
story fallout 3 had vaults to test the
effects of white noise on inhabitants
the infamous Geary vault full of clones
and of course vault 1 I want to test how
a community deals with a dictatorial
overseer safe to say that fallout 4
contains
examples of the designers creativity
when coming up for the vault experiments
they're not very nice but exploring them
as great snippets of story on the
terminals bodies everywhere locked doors
with delicious goodies behind them
it's like Aladdin's cave if Aladdin was
about supermutants and scavenging and
death so those are our five best moments
in Fallout 4 if you've had any exciting
death-defying moments in Boston lately
make sure you share them with us in the
comments below and anyone found posting
spoilers will be subjugated to the FEV
now as you guys know we like to take a
look at all the awesome stuff coming out
from the fallout community at the end of
each episode and despite everyone being
busy actually playing the game there are
still some great submissions and great
creations coming out from you talented
folk so let's take a look first up we've
got this awesome fallout tribute from
Josh 3000 this has taken elements from
quite a few Fallout games you can see
our companions from fallout 3 the red
rocket and the power noodle from fallout
4 and it doesn't look like the most
welcoming scene but very well done
nonetheless and we're actually going to
look at our first mod which is something
I didn't think would happen for quite
some time with or without official mod
support there is already a graphical mod
to make the game look that little bit
nicer on PC so here we can see it in
default and then as the transition pans
over you can see the colors are a little
bit more vibrant the lighting is a
little bit brighter and whilst the game
already looks amazing a lot of people
kind of keep you the graphics but I
think fallout 4 looks like an awesome
game but this is just stepping it up a
little bit more so if you've got a PC
system that can handle a little bit more
juice and a little bit more graphical
intensity then I recommend you download
this mod and enjoy all the wonderful
sights the wasteland has to offer a
handy little tool coming up next fallout
4 map comm so someone has actually
mapped or it's currently mapping the
locations for armor weapons holotapes
anything unique all the settlements
everything a budding wasteland needs in
the world of fallout 4 and you can find
them on this interactive map so if
you're searching for you
weapon or you want to know how to find
the five hidden games that you can play
on your pip-boy you can refer to this
map check them out for yourself and then
go back into your game and wander to
them I will say the it is possible to
wound yourself with some minor spoilers
when using this map for example some of
the weapons are quest rewards but am a
great tool and very useful nonetheless
and finally we have something called
when you play too much Fallout by
Rameses the pigeon awesome name
so Ramses has been playing too much and
this is how we've used the world now
getting vats outside a McDonald's having
action points to attack with scissors
trying to pass speech tests with with
doctors with not much chance of success
tinder on your pip-boy 121 years old
might be a bit too old for me and the
perk afternoon nap I think that's
something I should invest in but as much
fallout as I've been playing I haven't
lost my mind this much yet I don't think
I'm close but those are all the awesome
submissions that we've got from the
Fallout community this week if you want
to submit anything yourself send us a
picture of you wearing your pip-boy any
impressive settlements you've made any
art and he cosplay anything like that
make sure you tweet at us with the
hashtag GS fallout
I've been Dave thank you so much for
watching this week's episode of the
fallout 4 show taking time out of your
busy schedule of actually playing
fallout 4 until next time remember to
subscribe to the fallout 4 show and like
the video and stay safe out there
wasteland err
the sweat now piece well it's a
beautiful day gonna burn my truck I'm
going